this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
premium subscription India is home to
1.3 billion people in just five years
it'll pass China and become the most
populous country on the planet and it
shows the streets are chaotic
markets overcrowded and its economy
bursting with potential while it's still
decades behind on basic infrastructure
like schools and sanitation India's GDP
is among the fastest growing in the
world which for companies means 1.3
billion potential customers many of whom
are using the internet for the first
time ever
where Amazon Google and uber struggled
to enter and compete with locals like
Baidu and Alibaba in China they've
largely succeeded in India with one big
exception Apple is almost nowhere to be
found the iPhone is an unstoppable
money-making machine more successful
than Boeing's 737 Toyota's Corolla and
the entire Star Wars franchise and yet
here it only commands about 1% of the
whole smartphone market just in the last
year its government threatened to ban
the iPhone over a disagreement about
privacy Apple reportedly lost three key
Indian executives and it failed to get
approval for an official retail store
it's safe to say things aren't going so
well so what makes India so different
and what does it mean for the future of
Apple
this is the sales miracle known as the
iPhone Apple went from selling 1 million
in 2007 to 11 in 2008 all the way to a
record-breaking 231 million in 2015
turns out people like bigger phones the
trend couldn't be more clear but then
something changed in the last three
years sales have been flat and if we
look at all smartphones you can see
Apple is no exception
what was 40 or 50 or even 60 percent
growth has now become zero
now if flat means consistently selling
200 million premium devices year after
year well that doesn't sound so bad
the iPhone isn't declining it's just not
growing but Apple of course is a public
company and the stock market is based on
the expectation of growth it's not
enough to make an unbelievable amount of
money it needs to make an unbelievable
amount more than last year which brings
us back to the basics there are three
ways Apple can sell an iPhone someone
buying their first smartphone someone's
switching from a competitor or someone
upgrading their current iPhone the first
two have been incredibly fruitful and
are still responsible for millions of
sales but there are only so many humans
on earth and at least for now Apple is
not in the business of making more which
brings us to the third category the
customers it already has for the average
person that two year upgrades are
becoming three or four or whenever this
phone dies upgrades premium smartphone
companies are in the business of making
better longer-lasting devices that will
entice more people to upgrade but that
also makes them less eager to upgrade in
the future it's a tough game to play
we've reached a point where most people
are mostly happy with what they have in
some ways Apple is too successful for
its own
good today it may sell the same number
of phones but more profit is being made
thanks to the higher prices of the 10
and 10 s plus existing users are
valuable in more ways than one we buy
Apple music iCloud storage Apple watch
air pods and soon Apple streaming video
so this graph the company argues can
only say so much that's why it no longer
publishes the number of phones sold sure
sales may be flat but the average
selling price is anything but the last
two years have proven people are willing
to pay eleven twelve fourteen hundred
dollars in other words this strategy is
working but it can't go up forever
somewhere there's a limit and that's why
emerging markets are if not existential
at least very important for the future
of the company so Apple in need of
customers meat India in need of phones
sixty-three thousand Indians are pulled
out of extreme poverty every day and
companies can hardly wait now in terms
of raw GDP India ranks an impressive
sixth place right behind the United
Kingdom but adjusted per capita it's
only one thousand nine hundred and
thirty nine dollars to China's eight
thousand eight hundred and twenty seven
meanwhile the cheaper iPhone ten are
starts at seven hundred and forty nine
dollars and that's if you're a lucky
American in India the price is seventy
seven thousand rupees or around eleven
hundred dollars and again that's the
cheaper model the 10s on the other hand
is upwards of one thousand four hundred
and twenty dollars here Apple strategy
of raising prices is backfiring an
estimated 75% of smartphones are sold
for less than two hundred and fifty
dollars and ninety five percent less
than five hundred for most people the
iPhone is simply too expensive even the
much older iPhone 6 and se are sold at
relatively high prices
for that kind of money customers expect
a brand new phone not a three or five
year old one most Indians don't even buy
smart phones but basic feature phones
like the geophone which is effectively
free with a small refundable deposit so
the iPhone is a tiny sliver of the
premium market which is only a small
segment of smartphone sales which
account for less than half of all phone
sales there's just not that much pie
left now Apple has never purely been
driven by unit sales or market share for
the most part it's just not interested
in selling to all price points but this
market share is barely even noticeable
unfortunately price is only one part of
the problem it also lacks brand
recognition is affected by a weaker
currency plus tariffs and even for those
that can't afford it the iPhone in India
just isn't as good a product
it lacks Apple pay Apple Maps is let's
say limited and Siri still has trouble
understanding local accents some of
Apple's most undervalued assets are it's
over 500 retail stores across 19
countries it builds giant glass cubes
renovates historic theaters and
practically defies the laws of physics
not because it's cool well not just
because it's cool but because they make
insane amounts of money no other company
makes more money per square foot of
retail space and if you have any doubt
about that I dare you to walk through
one without bumping into anyone but all
this means nothing in India here phones
are sold in small local shops where
brands have little to no control not the
best conditions for a company which
regulates the height of its tables and
at least for now it legally can't open a
store the Indian government requires
that any foreign owned company by at
least 30% of its materials within the
country before opening a retail store in
response Apple has started manufacturing
the SA
and success in India which it may soon
do for newer phones as well in the
meantime Chinese brands like oneplus
Oppo and VEVO carefully target the
Indian market by producing low-cost
locally manufactured devices ultimately
the reason Apple can't compete is simple
it's not willing to adapt the company
has all the resources in the world but
unless it makes a significant change in
strategy India will never be the next
China the iPhone accounts for over 60%
of Apple's total revenue to continued
growth it has no choice but to do what
Apple does best destroy its own thriving
product with an entirely new category
since reaching a 1 trillion dollar
market cap Apple stock has been
unusually shaky sometimes this is
significant sometimes it's normal market
fluctuations and you can tell the
difference by understanding ideas like
statistical variance which you can learn
with brilliant you don't want to panic
and sell here which is why this
knowledge pays off that's the power of
topics like math logic and machine
learning combined with economics you can
see a business from a whole new
perspective if you like learning new
things and clearly you do you'll love
the way brilliant helps you understand
new ideas not just memorize their
formulas to get started go to brilliant
org slash poly matter and sign up today
for free the first 200 people to use
that link will also get 20% off the
annual premium subscription thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
to you for listening
you